der hat wie ich finde eine
Grenzüberschreitung gemacht die ich von
ihm bisher nicht gehört habe nämlich
nicht mehr gesagt die Leute empfinden es
so dass Arbeit sich nicht lohnt darüber
könnte man ja diskutieren oder über die
Größe von Abständen sondern er hat
gesagt es lohnt sich nicht arbeiten zu
gehen er hat das als Tatsache
dargestellt dass Menschen die
Transferleistung kriegen mehr kriegen
und das ist man muss das so deutlich
sagen einfach ja nicht gesagt selbst
wenn es sozusagen eins zu eins ist lohnt
es sich quasi nicht mehr das ist aber
auch nicht eins zu eins unser
Sozialstaat über den man diskutieren
kann in seiner ausgestalten man kann
über Prozentsätze frei betrinken man
kann über alles reden aber er ist vom
Grundkonstrukt her so aufgebaut dass es
immer auch die Bürger Geldreform im
letzten Jahr eine Anreiz hin zur Arbeit
gibt
[Musik]